you had a vacation like five days now no
vacation got to work man no you know what
it was good you know what we got to see a
little bit of the countryside like in terms
of like the Penguins in Philips Island
yeah it was great what about kangaroo I
saw a kangaroo like in wild or um just
on the side of the road yeah oh yeah
yeah this is the National Hockey League's
first time down under Aussie people are
great the sports fanatics luckily for us
we get to see that firsthand it's a great
opportunity for the NHL to you know
grow the game here wants a lifetime
experience hockey's a great sport we'd love
to turn a bunch of Australians into hockey
fans glad you could join us for what is an
historic event it's the first time in NHL
history a game has been played not only in
Australia but in the southern hemisphere ah
back at it boys come on let's have a good game
gentlemen back help him out boys what do you
want hey hey so I should have
probably went into the corner
and then the L yeah feeds it down
low schmalz to Keller in two deep
and he scores Clayton Keller has
the coyotes in front got him I got
him that sucks slow hey hey hey nice shot I got to
tip that nice shot I got to tip that
hey hold up the net in the middle CR
scores you got that 3-1 Arizona oh Bo
crer nice rip 67 to win a face up here
yeahp
jump 3 to one coyotes dancing cooly scores
yes Co get what a goal by the youngster you
know that was one of the best goals I've ever
seen the spinner am is one thing but then you
know to have the the patience to pull a
tier forehand and then finish it that is
something you cannot teach one of the best
I've ever seen hey told you it was an easy
leag told you You' get adoped you know I
thought I had some space and I thought I
miss the net actually but saw the guys put
their arms up so definitely felt good to
get that one and you know it was awesome game
to play in what a skill goal you it's going
to be an honor to referee here that skill as
the horn ends game one here in Melbourne 53
Arizona great atmosphere fans were definitely
involved and you know cheering all game and it
was fun to jump right into that NHL feel and
atmosphere from Rod labor Arena in Melbourne
Australia the NHL Global series continues
you ready 3 2 1 good luck coill that's
all they call you coill yeah nice nice hope
you all enjoyed it good all the best welcome
again everybody to game two of this weekend
set the building will be full again as the
Aussies continue to show their support and
really Embrace NHL hockey go go good T not
necessary right now oh no just send it I'm going
to go on the far side yeah I'm I'm I'm here I'm
here go go go Power Play winding down in
tight a chance and a goal Barrett Hatton
for the game's first goal what do you want
last minute do something simple hey middle
up high fala feeds it right side
gets it back from kempe to Kee
one timer he scores we thought we
would have a hungry group nice job
Val that hurt I can tell we didn't know
how individuals would react or play but
they they answered the Bell they played pretty
darn hard shot score moara Jacob moara gives
the king their first lead but overall good
experience today and yesterday that will do
it with three third period goals the Kings
defeat Arizona 3 to2 here in the second game
of the global series weekend here in Australia
when you come to a new country you don't really
know how the game's going to be received give
the the fans in the city a lot of credit and
uh respect the way that they treated us and
the way that they came and showed up for us
the coyotes salute the crowd here the king
salute the crowd it has been fantastic you
see number of NHL jersey everywhere number of
fans and the way the people were cheering and
everything that I think that was pretty cool it's
an outstanding experience the people of Melbourne
the life in the city the energy the AFL game
go fans I would say it's an unreal experience